who do you think is gonna win this is it
gonna be Donald Cerrone or cowboy
MacGregor
I think Cowboys gonna maybe upset him
yeah yeah I don't even think is that
much of a happening well yeah it is Cle
it would be yeah but why is everyone
think you should 100 ugh everyone just
think he's gonna roll over that's not
true isn't that weird to you it's a
little bit weird as much as 170 yeah
that boy has lost the last two fights
though he has lost his tooth Lester
doesn't want to find three years though
right and I haven't seen um and am I out
of it I haven't seen any talk any hype
now why is that I don't know there's
nothing so weird to me right then I got
buildup here's the other things that
you've UFC goes I don't know if they
announced it maybe Dana did a little bit
he didn't really dive into it but they
go fastest sellout t-mobile we saw out
30 minutes and even that was you know
few weeks ago even I was like that damn
comeback but they look more into a lot
of bots but the tickets the the tickets
are every game by her yeah why do you
only knows why he's like not to do as
Connor a hasn't done pressed B the yeah
he doesn't want to fight three years I
mean you know there's a lot that goes
into it yeah and I wonder yes - we might
he might be yeah he might be a little
nervous about creating a lot of hype if
he lose no I don't think he's nervous I
just think he's if you saw the interview
like great interview with Aroha Hwanhee
seasoner he's dialed in yeah you're
Connor feeling like oh yeah he said he
hasn't he hasn't had a drink in like
months three four buds yeah which I was
like Donald Donald sticks to the game
plan kicks front kicks him I would front
kick him and hear a game plan do you
have a Brendan when you were fighting
did you ever like two questions one did
you ever go into a fight like through if
the fights the arena and you had to poop
or pee pee everyone - you ever get do
you ever get kicked in the face and what
what really knocked out was the smell of
the guys foot those are legit question
because I know people ask you all these
what's it like I know that you're
fearless and a maniac and nuts and you
have mental health issues because you're
fighting in the [ __ ] Arctic down like
that I know that that's true but I want
to know what guys do you smell like a
mess - a poop or pee pee yeah every
every I think every time your your nurse
you have to pee
sorry fight at the p-block it out and I
know because I know like people have
asked like you know roll around a guy
get like attracted to a guy because that
would be
I think no I'm not trying to be funny
Michael my thing would be finding with a
guy like that especially a handsome guy
like you like if you were my opponent I
would train and I'd be like I want to
kill you but then if we're nestling up
like that and especially be catching
with a kick you know to certain part of
my body and I get an erection in the
ribs
are you in a getting kicked around you
know what happened to getting kicked
around I'm into starting monogamous
relationships with men I feel like
you're being metaphorical but I'm super
do is get a [ __ ] mortgage with you
man you're [ __ ] really good morning
you know but I just I don't know you
know yeah well I wouldn't know the
answer that questions your money I was
able to fight the drought cold then
where's your money on this where's your
money on this fight oh you know I love
Donald I love Donald but if cowboy
everybody Cerrone comes correct so I
mean if Connor comes correct you really
yeah you think Connors okay at 170 like
being like I think so cuz because
Cerrone he's not a huge 170 you know
he's not like a like a daring tale or a
Woodley or one of those monsters like
sorority real weight was 55 he is
successful at 55 he's good at 70 but
they're both tweeners so it makes for
Connors comeback fight it makes all the
sense of the world right Diamond I want
out
I love I love Donald and Don's a
personal friend I just wanted to get
paid yeah I strongly get paid right
because either even if he wins there's
not a lot left for right just get paid
yeah for the sport it's probably better
if Connor wins way better for those
secret business it's way better yeah he
only beats like little or guys who's
that Connor
like he never the second time yeah but I
mean it was like it could have kind of
got if there was like a little more time
on the clock he could've got choked out
of the hour I was a thick dude Chapman
is a thick dude
yummy yummy fifth pick is [ __ ] yeah I
said yummy yummy because I was 185 and
he's what's always not small no are
there any gay UFC fighters that are
alined that came out just there's a few
female Lisbon's yeah I feel I mean all
but yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]